like when I first met you at the Comedy
Store is that where I first met you uh
yeah well I I'm not sure but you you
know you've always you've always had
really nice things to me you know and
like what looked back up look looked up
to me back in the day I say that's not
that's yeah out loud you do yeah yeah it
always warms my heart like you said God
you know one day I want to be like Tom
Rhodes in headlines yeah yeah yeah like
that 100% and then when I met you you
said something you go come to my place
in by La Brea where is used to live
there now I live yeah grow up by the by
the UH yeah yeah by the Grove with your
beautiful wife she is divorcing me she
moved out New Year's Eve I thought you
knew that
I spent January alone in my apartment
crank thanks for bringing that up
yeah we're getting divorced
yeah the pen should be finally yeah
should be finalized anything oh my [ __ ]
well that's this a good way to start the
really great but how would I know that
you didn't tell me uh well you know when
you run into someone at the Comedy Store
it's you know you don't want to dump
your problems only I know but my wife's
the thing is is that you it would be
something that because now I feel like a
fool no you didn't know cuz I cuz when
you when you guys were together I
thought to myself oh my god what a
beautiful [ __ ] couple like she was
making a dinner play whenever and she
was like very she's got a Europe she's
from England correct
she's from Holland Holland Murata yeah
her ethnicity is Indian yeah from
Surinam very pretty very like just nice
Mercer now surname is in England surname
is one of those little countries of a
Brazil yeah it's you got English Guiana
French Guyana Suriname Venezuela
yeah there's Brazilians that don't even
know surname isn't it orders there so I
go to my trick question what is your
hair when we play geography games in
Suriname is my go to no kidding that's a
good people my mother's from Argentina
and
I've got cousins there I've been there
four times and my cousin's in Argentina
when I first got with my wife
they said they issued we really want you
to be with the South American woman and
I said I am with a South American woman
they didn't even know her name was on
their own country Wow
it's a stumper that's a good I don't
want to get into why it's actually a
really good story man it was her idea I
was against it and she used to travel
with me everywhere she's a photographer
and you know I play all over the world
so we were a great couple you know I was
looking for jokes she was looking for
photos or thing is street photography
and then a year ago she decided she
didn't want to travel anymore
so she went with me to Hong Kong with
him to Paris
but we kind of lost our connection and
during travel you lost your connection
well me being away oh you being away
because when she traveled with me it was
great yeah and we're still really great
friends and there was there's no hard
feelings she thought it would make us
better artists and there was no
infidelity no major catastrophe to deal
with so we just split what we had and I
still talk to her all the time we're
great friends she's still in she did
yeah Wow
so you're now it's like January February
was really rough for me and then yeah
March and April is a lot better I'm how
long were you married seven years we
were together for ten oh that's amazing
because I well I mean not amazing use
words I don't even know what they mean
really well I didn't that was the wrong
word for that month I said that was a
bitter sell amazing there are couples
friends that would invite us over for
like couples get together right you know
I'm worried like that's not gonna happen
now that I'm yeah single guy I enjoyed
being married yeah and I thought I was
gonna be married the rest of my life so
it's it's a surprise and I'm starting to
think that she really did love me by
divorcing me giving me my life back
yeah oh yeah I know weird did you find
your comedies different now or yeah i
mean i i'm gonna i can write the next
chapter of my life so i'm writing the
next hour now so it's i gotta get rid of
all the stuff I was doing about being
married do yet darn European woman yeah
yeah yeah yeah do I have to leave you I
didn't come here to play the ideas I'm
just make a sacrifice for you to be a
better artist no no I don't think so um
you know I'm not going anywhere okay no
I mean I I I think that um when I wasn't
kidding when it back in when I was
younger and I wasn't I had no money and
I couldn't you know get a girlfriend or
even friends for that matter and I was a
stand-up I felt like I was a lot more um
hungrier that's always the case right I
wrote a lot more I tried give more
things because I had nothing to lose and
then as time goes on you have you gather
things and relationships and if you
build a foundation and then you you fear
losing things and then you don't take as
many risks and then you yeah I I think
that what I need to do is I need to put
myself in an uncomfortable situation so
I can revive that side of me but I can
do it without destroying my life I think
yeah yeah you can because I've seen your
bill burr doesn't he's got a beautiful
wife you know baby cut me a baby and the
whole thing and then I don't believe in
that are you know to be a great artist
you have to destroy your life you know I
think you can yes I believe that too
yeah but it's easier so was that was
that the main reasoning behind the
separation is you know you'd be better
artists or was I also think we started
to bore the [ __ ] out of each other well
the last couple of years I think we were
pretty set in our
tene so yeah I think that might have had
something to do with it right but you
guys are still you're good and all the
friends I heard dearly she loves me
dearly and you know I wanted to succeed
where she's still helping me with a few
projects and she still had it's my
podcast
oh yeah we're tight okay good good good
yeah because you're like it's weird you
know like when Gwyneth Paltrow in that
Chris Martin guy when I heard the words
conscious uncoupling I wanted to vomit I
thought it was pretentious thing I had
ever heard in my life I would never use
that terminal is it conscious uncoupling
where it's sort of an amicable decision
to part ways without you know putting in
a lot of thought not too much a bad
feeling involved conscious way to
separate and do good for each other for
whatever partnership to break up and
still be friends
yeah and I've got an old gay friend and
I was talking him about and he said you
know that's 80% of gay relationships and
like that where you still care about the
person and you don't want to destroy
them and you don't hate them right you
know yeah but I have maturity but I've
you know here's the thing with me is it
I've been in relationships as well and
we I've broken up obviously as well and
then but for me and and there's no hard
feelings you know me I don't have any
hard feelings toward Christine or Sarah
or any my previous girlfriends do I see
them and talk to them no but there's a
difference though because I am - what am
i - my best friends in my life happened
to be my exes when we went to the
wedding this weekend two of them were at
the wedding we share a lot of friends in
common who Matt and who guard oh oh
that's right Karl oh yeah but that's
because I think that's a testament to
the friendship we truly had during the
relationship my other exes I couldn't
give two shits about I couldn't I
wouldn't you know stop to think I worry
about what they're doing with their
lives but I think that's a testament to
the lack of friendship we had during
that relationship so you can if I mean
for it sounds like you guys were truly
friends to each other we genuinely loved
each other yeah and I think it's a
rarity and it's it's
you you know what I'm talking about also
my first love of my adult life Natalie
this French woman that I lived with in
San Francisco for seven years I'm still
great friends with her been my whole
life
where's Natalie now in San Francisco she
bought the we had we lived on the top
floor of this old Victorian mansion yeah
she bought it in like 1997 for three
hundred and fifty thousand dollars I
think it's worth six million oh yeah
she's awesome and her and her mom like I
got so much and even Ashna is my wife
I'm still very close with her mother
and the family I love all those people I
don't I don't ever want to cut them out
of my life like why should those have to
disintegrate if you've built 10 years of
this life together all of that doesn't
have to disappear
[Music]